رفضت موسكو الشرطه الامريكيه للتفاوض بين
البلدين واعلنت فشل المفاوضات مع واشنطن
وحلف شمال الاطلسي ومنظمه الامن والتعاون
في اوروبا
للصواريخ وكشف الولايات المتحده عن قاذفه
الاستراتيجيه الجديده قبل ايام من اطلاق
اليابان وبريطانيا وايطاليا مشروع انتاج
مقاتله النفاثه متطوره جديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقشه في
مسارات الثلاثه ما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله
لاعلاني موسكو فشل محاوله التفاوض مع
الغرب على التوتر الذي تمر به العلاقات
بين روسيا والقوه الغربيه وما دلاله
انغلاقي القنوات التفاعل بين القوه الكبرى
مع الاعلان عن الانخراطها في انتاج
البرامج التسليح الهجوميه ودفاعيه متطوره
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تؤثر هذه الاجواء في
السلام والاستقرار العالمي وما امكانيه
نجاحها في اعاده سباق التسلح بين القوه
الكبرى في العالم
[موسيقى]
بعد ايام من مناورات صينيه روسيه شاركت
فيها طائرات حربيه
بينها قاذفه بعيده المدى وبعد تعليق روسيا
مشاركته مشاركتها في اجتماعات اتفاقيه
ستار الجديده النوويه مع الولايات المتحده
اعلنا الكرملين ان محاولات التفاوض مع
واشنطن ومنظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا
من اوكرانيا وهو ما اعتبره الكرملين امرا
غير ممكن مؤكدا ان العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا مستمر
الرئيس الامريكي كان قد اكد استعداده
للحديث مع الرئيس الروسي الذيمر بوتين اذا
انسحب اذا انسحبت روسيا من اوكرانيا وهو
مستبعد بيض حدوثه
واحده لانهاء هذه الحرب
واحد يبدو انه لن يفعل ذلك انه يدفع ثمن
باهظا لفشله في القيام بذلك لكنه تسبب في
ما ذبحه لا تصدق لسكان المدنيين في
اوكرانيا
حضور رعايه الاطفال ما يفعله شيء مقزز لكن
في الواقع ليس لدي اي قطط مريحه للاتصال
بالسيد بوتين ولكي اكون دقيقا في كلامي
انا مستعد للحديث الى بوتين اذا كانت هناك
في الواقع مصلحه في ان يبحث عن وسيله
لانهاء الحرب لم يفعل ذلك حتى الان
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور دونال جونسون الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه السابق في
وايضا من موسكو اندري فروله الخبير في
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه ومن بيروت العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ابدا بضيفي اندريه من موسكو
ما معنى
ما الذي نفهمه من اعلان الجانب الروسي ان
طرق الطرق الدبلوماسيه مع واشنطن والغرب
اصبحت مسدوده
ياض
هذه المساله سهل جدا روسيا عرضت لمرات
عديده ان الجلوس خلف طاوله المفاوضات
والتحدث مع الحكومه الاوكرانيه والاداره
الامريكيه والاداره الاوروبيه ولكن اذا
نظرنا موضوعيا وتذكرنا الاوضاع التي كانت
منذ سنه قبل العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
من قبل روسيا ممكن ان نتذكر ان روسيا
عارضت لدول النيته وامريكا قبل كل شيء
يتحدث عن حزمه عروض امنيه
التي تعتقد روسيا انها مهمه وانها تحديات
همم جديه للامن الروسي لم يقوم احد
بالتحدث عن هذه الوسائل بل زادت المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا قبل العمليه العسكريه
باشهر لذلك في هذا الضوء ليس هناك اي معنى
من
علق على ما تقوم به الحكومه الروسيه لانه
الان روسيا لا تراه همم رغبه حقيقيه
بالمفاوضه عن السلم هناك مسائل خاصه
ونادره وبعض السنوريات التي يتحدثون عنها
مثل همم
اتفاق الحبوب ولكن خطوات حقيقيه الى حتى
ينشطه للحكومه الروسيه او ايجاد اي حلول
موس كلها ترى هذا
السيد دون الجنس ايضا الرئيس الامريكي
يقول انه ليس في عجله من امره للتحدث مع
السيد بوتن وكانه ليس هذا شيئا خطيرا ان
ينقطع على الاتصال بين اكبر قوتين نوويتين
في العالم
عشان تيجي
علينا ان ننظر الى السجل بشكل اوسع وكامل
فما قاله الشيخ ضيف الروسي طبعا مساعدات
العسكريه الاوكرانيا حصلت بعد قيام روسيا
بغزوه اوكرانيا وتحدثت عن ضم البلاد
والتخلص من زعماءها
في الاسبوع الماضي
الغا ذلك في اخر لحظه لانه كان الحديث
اوكرانيه تنتهي في ساحه المعركه وروسيا
تشعر به اسود تقوم بالهجوم على اهدافهم
المدنيه
على ساحه الماء على الارض لان الوضع غير
مناسب لمحادثات لاحقا ولكن ليس الان ولكن
حينما لا لا ليس الوقت مناسبا للمحادثات
الان واقفه معك سيد جنسد هل هذا يعني ان
كل القنوات الاتصال الروسيه الامريكيه
منقطعه ام ان هنالك قنوات اتصال
عسكريه مخابراتيه تمنع اندلاع حرب نوويه
او اشتباك بين قوتين نوويهتين
سؤال لك سيد جنسن
تمام
مره مره اخرى هم لا يتبادلان للحديث ولكن
مسؤول الشيعي ايوه والتقى بما نظيره في
تركيا قبل اسبوعين اذا هناك قنوات
مناسب للحديث في الوقت الذي ان الحرب
الجاريه والغزل الرئيس يدفع للوراء
عميد الياس حنا هذا هذا الانقطاع اتصال
السياسي وليس الاتصال الاستراتيجي ياتي في
وقت يتم الحديث والاعلان فيه في موسكو وفي
اليابان وفي الولايات المتحده عن اسلحه
جديده واسلحه استراتيجيه كالقاذفه همم
مثلا همم ب 21 الامريكيه التي تدخل الخدمه
العامه المقبل وغيرها صواريخ روسيه همم
متطوره لا مثيل لها كما يعلن الروس هل
هناك رابط بين الامرين هل نحن في ازاء او
امام سباق تسلح جديد كالذي حدث همم في
الحرب البارده وصل الى ما يسمى بحرب
النجوم
زين العابدين هذه التجارب هي احدى الرسائل
التي تعيد رسم معادله الردع بين القوى
الكبرى هي وسيله لاظهار القدرات لاظهار
النوايا
الاشتباك الحقيقي اليوم يجري في اوكرانيا
ولكن اليوم تظاهر تحالفات كبيره اليابان
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكوريا
مناورات معينه تجربه الطائره الشبح البي
21 هي شيء جديد مهم جدا حتى تجربه همم
الغواصه النوويه واطلاق الصاروخ دولافا
ايضا هو شيء مهم جدا حتى همم يعني تجربه
لصاروخ السمات النووي قبل نهايه السنه كل
هذه مواضيع تدخل في اطار عرض القوه اعاده
رسم همم كما قلت يعني معادله الردى وبالت
همم
التجربه الحقيقيه التي تجري والحك
والخطوط التماثل الدمويه هي تجري في
اوكرانيا وليس فعلا هناك انقطاع تام
الانقطاع هو بين الدولتين الانقطاع هو على
المستوى الاعلى ولكن البارحه كان مدير
الساعه ايه في تركيا هناك اتصال من الوزير
شويكو ايضا بوزير الدفاع نظيره الامريكي
بعد نحن نتحدث عن اداره الازمه تحت
الطاوله كي لا يكون هناك حسابات خاطئه
والذهاب الى ما لا يحسب عقبه همم سباق
التسارع طبعا مثير ايضا من ضمن الاشياء
والعلن المذكر ايضا همم بما اا اعلنه
الروس في وسط هذه الاجواء في الانستالات
في قنوات التفاهم السياسيه بين روسيا
والغرب اعلنت القوه الجويه الروسيه انها
اختبرت بنجاح منظومه دفاعيه جديده مضاده
للصواريخ والاهداف الجويه في حقل اختباري
بك كازاخستان
واشنطن كشفت من جانبها ايضا عن قاذفتها
الاستراتيجيه الشبح الجديده ب 21
التي اكد البنتاجون العمود الفقري لقوه
الولايات المتحده من القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه في المستقبل وذلك لان لها
نطاقا وقدره وقوه مختلفه هذه القذيفه
الجديده تتميز
بانها يمكن ان تعمل بلا طاقم وايضا
ويستبدا العام القادم تتميز بقدرتها على
تنفيذ ضربات النوويه بعيده المدى بالاضافه
الى استخدامها اسلحه تقليديه
ليس هذا اليابان وبريطانيا وايطاليا خرطت
هي الاخرى في اجواء تطوير برامج التسلح
باعلانها عن اتفاقيه ستوقع في وقت مبكر من
الاسبوع المقبل لتطوير مقاتله النفاثه
المتطوره الجديده بشكل مشترك رويترز كانت
قد اعلنت فيوليوت الماضي عن مثلا لدمج
مشروع المقاتل النفاثات تنفيست بقيره
البريطانيه مع برنامج مقاتله اف اكس
اليابانيه وستكون هذه المره الاولى التي
تتعاون فيها اليابان مع دول اخرى غير
الولايات المتحده في مشروع ان رئيسي
للمعدات الدفاعيه
عود مره اخرى الى ضيوفي وعود اليك مره
اخرى الياس حنا هذه الاسلحه التي تحدثنا
عنها ماذا تضيف في
المواجهه الحاليه بين روسيا والغندا
ااه زين العابدين انها اسلحه لن تستعمل
على المسرح الاوكراني لانه مسرح ضيق وهو
مسرح خطير جدا ولكنها اسلحه هي ليست سباق
تسلح كما يقال لانه هذه الاسلحه هي عمليه
تحديث للسلاح يعني عمليه تحديث للسلاح
النووي عمليه دقه عمليه سنسر اكثر منها
عمليات همم كميه البي 21
هي همم ابطا من سابقتها هيا ارخص من
سابقاتها الامر الذي قد يتيح لها ان يكون
هناك العدد الكبير منها ولكنها هي شبح
قادره على
تنفيذ مهمات على مسافات بعيده وهذا
الموضوع هو سباق تسلح هو تحديث السلاح
السابق لان التكنولوجيا تطورت بشكل ملحوظ
جدا واليوم نتحدث عن ليس سباق تسلح على
المستوى الاستراتيجي هو النووي لانه لن
يستعمل حتى الان انما يجب الحديث عن
السلاح التكتيكي السلاح التقليدي الذي
يجري استعماله على السحب اوكرانيا نتحدث
عن ثوره تكنولوجيه في هذا السلاح واحدها
والذي غير وجه المعادله الهيمرس على سبيل
النساء واختبار روسيا البارحه الصواريخ
المضاده للصواريخ اليوم نتحدث عن التقليد
كدقيق وثوره في هذا المجال وتحديث
العمليات همم النوويه لانه النووي لا
اعتقد انه قد يستعمل ضد دول العظمى بين
بعضها البعض
من موسكو هل تعتقد ايضا انه اننا لسنا في
صدد سباق تسلح لاسيما ما اعلنته
ومسترون امريكيون عن ان الصين ضاعفت او
تريد ان تضاعف قدرتها النوويه في غضون
السنوات المقبله لتمتلك الفا وخمس مئه راس
نوويه في السنوات المقبله وهو ثلاثه اضعاف
ما تمتلكه الان بحسب ما يقوله الامريكيون
بجانب المناورات الروسيه الصينيه
حلقت فيها طائرات استراتيجيه اذا لم يكن
هذا سباق تسلح فماذا يكون
ما يقوم به كل الاطراف يصل الى همم انواع
اسلحه جديده خاصه ان الزميل من لبنان قال
عن بعض انواع هذه الاسلحه ان الطباق
التسلح ليس في ما يصنعه اليوم وتحدثت عن
الطائره تحدثهم عن الطائره الامريكيه التي
استعرضوها من قريب وتكلمتم عن الصواريخ
الروسيه ولكن بوجهه نظري همم
الحقيقي ليس في هذه الاسلحه
الاسلحه التي تعمل بمبادئ جديده والتي
يعملون على تصميمها في الكثير من الدول
والحديث هنا عن الاسلحه فوق الصوتيه
والصواريخ
التي عن طريق الليزر وربما اجيال جديده من
الاسلحه النوويه الاصغر حجما والتي ممكن
ان يسيطر على التفجير النووي لها
هذه الاسلحه النوويه
فقر ممكن ان تستخدم بالمعارك اذا كانت
محدوده الوزن لذلك
السباق التسلح يسير ونحن نرى ان هذه
الدوامه بدات وسوف تزيد اكثر واكثر ليست
بين روسيا وامريكا فقط بل كما ذكرتم سوف
ينضم العام الصيني والهندي واعتقد ان في
السنوات العشر القادمه سوف نرى الزيد من
الصرف على الانظمه العسكريه في اغلب الدول
سفير دونالدز جونسون تقييمك لما يجري همم
ضيفه يقول انه سبق تسلل واحد ضيفنا من
بيروت يقول انه هذا التطور الطبيعي للجيوش
عموما في العالم كيف تراه وانت
على وضعك مصطلح السباق التسلح ولكن ما
اراه انا حسب رايي هو هو الذي يجعلني اتفق
مع الضيفين الروسي واللبناني ثم نشدنا هو
فعلا وتطور والنمو
اسلحه تقع ضمن الهندسه السابقه وكما قال
السيد روسي
الاسلحه ذات السرعه والتي مثل لقد حتى هي
ليس نوويه ولكنها وليس هناك اي قواعد في
العالم لتنظيم هذا النوع وهذا ما يحيط لنا
ما يطلق عن طريق الانترنت اذا نحتاج
لتحديث قوانيننا لتنظيم هذه التطورات كما
توصلنا قوانين وتنظيمه ما يحصل مع اتفاقيه
ستارت بعد بعد تنتهي الحاليه والثانيه
عدد كبير من انواع الدول
وايران وكوريا الشماليه الذين كانوا الذين
خارج سيطره على السلاح النووي حالي وعزلنا
بناخذ لا وبناخذها الدون نظر الاعتبار
ونضع قوانين لتنظيم هذا الامر لان الامر
غير مستقر وهو خطر واعتقد انه واشنطن ولكن
كبير اذا هذه التطورات
يعني يبدو الملك قلق امريكي كبير من نمو
الترسانه العسكريه الصينيه لسيمه الترسانه
النوويه ما هو الخوف ما مصدر الخلق يعني
الصين حتى ولو وصلت الى 1,500 وهي تقريبا
لا تصل حتى الى ثلث ما لدى الولايات
المتحده او لدى همم روسيا
هذا السؤال وجيه جدا
300 راس
العدد اكبر فال300 هو يبدو هدف بسيط ولكن
ان اتفاقيه ستارت لا تخص الصين
[موسيقى]
المفاوضات لا تشمل الصين في هذا الصوت
وبالتالي الصين تطور انظمتها خارج هذه
القواعد والقوانين والتي وضعت الاتحاد
السوفيتي المتحده سابقا لذلك المتحده
لانه اذا عملت الصين
في البيئه الاستراتيجيه الدوليه وبالتالي
علينا ان نشارك همم
الولايات المتحده وروسيا وقتها اخرى
للتواصل الى النظام الجديد لواجه التحديات
1500 راس نوويه هل هي مختلفه عن الصين
الموجوده حاليا التي ان تصبح القوه
الاقتصاديه الاولى في العالم
زين العابدين الخوف ليس من ال 1500 ولكن
ليس هناك من معاهدات تربط الصين بموضوع
اليه المراقبه والتفتيش كما حصل كما يحصل
في ستارت بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الصين لديها مشروع كوني انها
تطور حاملات الطائرات انها تطور لديها
مشاريع اساسيه في المحيط المباشر بين
تايوان جنوب بحر الصين وبالتالي لديها
الحزام والطريق الهدف هو هدف كوني السلاح
هذه الاسلحه هي لحمايه هذا المشروع هذا
اولا ثانيا اليوم التحالف غير المعلن
الرسمي بين الصين وروسيا يعني ان منطقه
اوراسيا هي منطقه محظور على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فاذا ما جمعنا السلاح
النووي الروسي والسلاح النووي الصيني تصبح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكانها تقاتل
على جبهتين نوويتين هذا بالمعنى النووي
هذا عدا القتال على جبهات متعدده باسلحه
غير تقليديه وفي اماكن غير تقليديه نبدا
من تايوان وقد تنتهي وقد لا تنتهي
باوكرانيا هذا هو الخوف الاساسي حتى
باستراتيجيه الامن القومي للرئيس بايدن
والنيكلرناشونال ريفيو او بريفيو تحدث عن
الصين وكان هي الاساس ولم يتحدث عن روسيه
يعني تحدي الكبير هو اقتصادي اجتماعي
سياسي والقدره اليوم من يصنع همم رقاقات
الزكيه الصين تصنع روسيه تستورد هذا
الموضوع من هنا الخوف امريكا من الصين
روسيا والصين السيد فروله همم يعني هنالك
خصومه هيدروجيه وخصومه استراتيجيه الصينيه
روسيه قديمه هلا هذا التحالف تغلب على هذه
الخصومه اما هو تحالف مؤقتا
ان نتحدث عن الف او حلف بين روسيا
والصين بالمسائل العسكريه بالطبع بين
الدولتين هناك مصالح مشتركه يتفاوض عنها
ويوقع ويوقع الاتفاقات ولكن لا نستطيع
الحديث عن حلف مثلا مثل النيته او
الولايات المتحده
اي بريطانيا واستراليا هذه هي هذا الشيء
الاول اما الشيء الثاني ليس بين روسيا
والصين اي تضاربات حقيقيه كما كان في
الستينات او السبعينات نرى ان الان ان هذا
احد افضل
مراحل العلاقات بين الدولتين وعندما تتحدث
عن الاتفاقات
همم تتحدث عنها او متحدث عنه
انا ايه اتفاقات بين الولايات المتحده
وروس هو شيء غير مستقر لانه يتخلى عن هذه
الاتفاقات
الخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه واشكر
ضيفنا من واشنطن الدكتور دونا الجينسن قد
الوسيله امريكا السابق واضحا من بيروت
العميد الياس حمن الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي تنتهي هذه الحلقه اذن بهذا
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر رعايه
[موسيقى]